meanwhile the white house is hitting
back at texas governor greg abbott this
in response to the governor's plan to
put illegal immigrants onto buses and
drive them to the u.s capitol here's jen
saki
i think it's pretty clear this is a
publicity stunt his own
office admits that a migrant would need
to voluntarily be transported and he
can't compel them to because again
enforcement of our country's immigration
laws lies with the federal government
not a state washington dc well listen i
don't know but i know that the governor
of texas or any state does not have the
legal authority to compel anyone to get
on a bus
governor abbott announced the plan
yesterday calling it a response to the
president's unwillingness to protect the
border
so the immigration issue expected to
have a big impact on the midterms karl
rove here with analysis on that carl
good morning to you i know you got a
white board but but here are um
here's the list of senators one two
three four five five of them are
democrats
that oppose drop in title 42.
um call forward number five guys and
just as a backdrop here carl this was
the headline from
march 20th falci says u.s unlikely to
see surge from new coven 19 variant all
right that's on march 20th but this
headline from yesterday
where we are likely to see a surge in
the fall
so fauci's seen it both ways over the
past three weeks
you think about what his position is you
think about these democratic centers up
for re-election in november are i think
title 42 arguably could come back yet
again over the next several weeks your
view it is what
well first of all you put your finger on
one of the most important things the
people on the democratic side have come
out in favor of this are up for election
this year in vulnerable democrats and
battleground states and they recognize
how volatile this is the president's
approval on the handling of immigration
last year in march of last year was 40
percent
today it is 32 percent
and if we see 18 000 people a day coming
across the border
then we're going to see those numbers
sink even lower
i loved it jen pasake said it's the
federal government's responsibility to
enforce the immigration laws not the
states so therefore he can't do it well
when is the federal government going to
start enforcing the law the state of
texas is spending
millions of dollars
every week in order to fill the gaps on
the border that the border patrol openly
says we don't have enough resources
technology and people demand i spent the
last weekend with the father of one of
the national guardsmen deployed to the
border his son is telling them that
every night his squad is out there all
night long with night vision goggles and
heavily armed and they take fire from
across the river the mexican cartels
shoot tracers in order to make certain
that their appearance is known and every
night they are picking up dozens of
illegals and they're in one very small
stretch maybe a couple of miles long on
the on the border and though our border
with text with mexico is hundreds of
miles long so this is a grave crisis for
the country and the non-shallot attitude
of of the white house jen posaki as she
gets ready to leave for cable tv news is
like we're in charge don't worry about
it we got it handled and they do not
have it handled and it's going to come
back to bottom big time in the election
i wanted to ask you about that carl just
the political calculation as well so the
white house can count they can see
what's happening to their poll numbers
on this but they seem to be making a
different calculation so i know that the
left-wing immigration groups that really
wanted title 42 to be lifted must they
must be very persuasive so when when
when the prime minister as i call him
ron claim the chief of staff is as as
they look at this maybe they think one
lifting it is the right thing to do on
the merits but there's something it
tells me that president biden wouldn't
necessarily have done this in his
previous you know position as a senator
he might have been one of those that had
been a co-sponsor to keep it
yeah
that's very interesting inside very very
key one because remember what the
progressives are saying or the
progressive caucus in the house and
progressive senators in the senate is
the reason your numbers are low is that
you aren't doing enough in pursuit of
progressive goals so they don't you know
that you haven't you you've got 42 of
title 42 still in place you will get
better paypal said pass bill back better
and do and put the 71 executive orders
including the the
the ending of title 42
prohibitions at the border and democrats
will gain seats in the congress so the
mindset of the progressives is
you've got to do these weird things like
get rid of title 42 and and end student
debt all together and make these other
changes that we can't get passed through
law and executive order and that will
cause democrat enthusiasm to rise and
we'll have a good election in the fall i
think it's nutty and obviously so do
senators in places like new hampshire
and arizona and elsewhere who are in
hotly contested races
remember that says cdc were going to go
in their guidance a week ago right now
fauci fauci has had double speak in
three weeks carl in 21 days he's seen it
but he's seen both sides of these issues
coming up in the fall so thank you so
much we'll see what happens then karl
rove thanks in texas